わぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！
水素ロケットです。
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
おい！！！
俺は今怒っている。
夏休み中に、水素ロケットを上げる動画を出したと思うんですけども
今だ
あれ実は
商品が間違っておりまして
僕が頼んだのは
もっとしっかりした水素ロケットだったんですよ。
もっとなんかすごい威力がありそうな水素ロケットだったんですけども
商品を送ってくださる会社のミスで
違うロケットが届いたらしくて
「すいませんでした。」っていう電話がかかってきて
「少しの返金と本当は送るはずだった商品を送ります。」って言われて
今段ボールで荷物が届いて、こっちに来たんですけども
その商品がこちら
間違えた商品と同じです。
もーーーー！！！
同じよ、まったく同じ
「ちゃんとしたやつ送りますね」っていって、送ってきたのが、また間違いだったんです。
さすがのゴッドの俺も、これは許せねぇな...。
外でこの前上げたやつもなんか不発だったしさ
もう...
何もうまくいってないよ！
何もうまくいってないのに、さらに追加攻撃で違うのが届くという
もうどうなってんの！！！
もう、もうもうもうもうもう....
もう嫌
もう水素ロケット、もう嫌
だってこれ、本当は僕が欲しかったやつとはまた違ってて
あの外で打ち上げたときに失敗したやつと、同じやつでございます。
もう怒った！！！
家でやることにした！！
どうせ不発でしょ。もう知ってるよ。
外でちゃんとやって、不発だったんで
どうせ、また今回も上手くいかないんで、もう家でやります。
飛ばない水素ロケットを、外にやりにいく必要もないんで
もう俺は今日怒ってるよ！
もう、もういいよ。
意地でも俺にこのロケットをやらせたいんでしょう！
もうそういうことならこっちもその気でもう今回は
家の中で水素ロケットやりますから！
これ前も言ったんですけど
説明書が全部英語なので、なかなか難しいです。
行くぜ...
いい感じではないでしょうか。
できました。
よっしゃ～
（ピッ）
わぁっ！
もう嫌だぁぁ！！
というわけで、リベンジしてみたんですけども、うまくいきませんでした。
本当に申し訳ないです。
全部説明書英語だから、僕の手順のミスがあるかなと思って
今回入念に、ちゃんと説明書通りに作ったんですけど
本当に上手くいかなかったので
たぶん、打ちあがらないのかなって思いました。
何がダメだったんだろう？
本当に水の量も完璧にして
時間も全部完璧で
守るべきところは全部守ってやってんですけども
上手くいきませんでした。
どうなっているんでしょう。
ちょっと、本当わかんない！
たぶん次飛ぶときは、自分で水素ロケット作ると思います。
じゃあな！